on de koh lanta parce qu'on a encore des
révélations à vous faire sur cette
saison de koh lanta
jimmy alors je n'ai jamais vu c'est un
candidat parce que vous l'avez jamais vu
d'ailleurs puisqu'ils la saison est
annulé jimmy qui était candidat de koh
lanta nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ni en tout cas tu le vois dans la rue tu
sais que ça d'anciens candidats sans
rigoler c'est quoi yann égal ils ont
tous la même tête et j'ai vu j'ai vu
faire jimmy merci d'être là franchement
merci très content parce que tu es très
très en colère contre koh lanta non mais
c'est vrai on t'a vu de t'exprimer dans
diverses médias et tu souhaites exprimé
aujourd'hui tu voulais que le porte
parole des candidats qui sont très déçu
d'avoir été rapatriés
suite à cet événement parce que vous
avez tous été rapatriés au bout de
quatre jours on va parler des événements
dans un instant puisque on a encore des
nouvelles de nouvelles données mais toi
tu étais été déçu tu voulais rester déçu
mais pas en colère
ben tiens à préciser que je suis pas en
colère et paf et d'interviews c'est un
autre collègue de mon équipe
et là on va dire que c'est toi qu'est ce
qui s'est vraiment passé là bas qu'est
ce qui s'est passé pro vous êtes rentré
que vous a dit alors nous on n'a rien su
jusqu'à l'arrivée en france d'un corps
m'en voudrais juste vous prenez vos
affaires vous dégagez vous a dit de
personnes ont eu un problème et à
l'intégrité d'une personne disant je
donc ouais on préfère sur des cartes et
donc nous on a pensé violent assez
rapidement agression sexuelle donc
pourquoi personne n'a plus ou moins
tout le monde a accepté la décision de
la production il accepte encore lord
aujourd'hui malgré la colère la
frustration et tout ça alors vous avez
pris vous avez passé deux jours à
prendre connaissance bouquet avec les
candidats faire connaissance avec les
candidats
vous êtes vous ai connu candide donc
elle était dans votre équipe candide non
pas dans mon équipe alliant de l'autre
ici et là c'est samir 24 heures les 21
candidats ensemble
d'accord ça va vous entendiez bien avec
elle ces thérapies de 21 ans j'ai bien
sûr c'est 21h par donc pas 24 heures
ouais j'ai passé plus de temps à côtoyer
dit que candide mais eddy donc voilà il
dit qui est qui et qui donc qui attaque
et par parent candide comme community
eddy merckx été la star de la saison et
10 allait être une des uns des gros
personnage de la saison très fort
caractère et puis pas sa langue dans sa
poche
donc je pense que oui on aurait on avait
un gros candidat là alors et donc vous
quand vous avez appris ça il est dit est
ce que vous a dit que c'était normal
est-ce que vous avez emile casting je
sais qu'il y en a beaucoup qui disent
que le casting de cette année était très
très télé réalité est que voilà c'est ce
caniveau de collègues également il a dit
voilà aujourd'hui dans koh lanta c'est
plus des aventuriers ces dégâts de télé
réalité on en croit savoir on à l'info
voilà que c'est tf1 qui va me sourire
maintenant et qui demande à la
production c'est sage insee ara aprikian
lui même qui a pour objectif j'allais
dire mission même pas c'est lui qui
s'est fixé comme objectif de faire de
koh lanta une émission quasiment avec
des candidats qui pourraient de
télé-réalité l'on sait pas c'est pas une
si mauvaise idée que ça qu'il a parce
que c'est vrai qu'on voit cathédrale des
mac marche très bien il s'est dit je
vais mêler les deux aventures et télé
réalité mais vous vous voilà vous vous
avez sans vous l'avez senti ça roulait à
100 je comprends pourquoi ils pourquoi
il a pu penser ça c'est vrai que dans
cette équipe bleue c'était l'équipe un
peu extraverti avec une métisse aux
cheveux bleus
un édit complètement à presque 1 qu'un
clou hors de contrôle
c'est dur il est très drôle il paraît
bresse qui ont coulé c'était une équipe
un peu excentrique donc je comprends
pourquoi et puis il a pu dire ça après
il était aussi très en colère on est
juste de débarquer sur le sol français
au moment où il ya eu cette interview
donc c'était des réactions à chaud alors
ce qui est important si vous le
permettez c'est qu'il a été dit qu'il y
avait déjà deux groupes qui s'étaient
formés que notamment justement la jeune
fille candide kenyane comme tout et eddy
s'était déjà extrêmement rapprochés
apparemment il paraît que ça était déjà
là c'est très chaleureux un truc qu'on
avait pas réellement de groupe on était
21 sur une plage pendant 24 heures c'est
pas c'est ce qu'a dit un de tes
collègues beaucoup trop tôt pour
commencer nord je pense qu'il l'a dit
quand ils ont été en équipe quand ils
les ont rejoint leur équipe et qu'ils
ont pu passer plusieurs jours ensemble
mais candide était effectif déjà avec
énormément de monde sur ces 24 heures
est pas est dit est dit garder une
réserve comme nous tous et on était
plusieurs être un peu choqué de se dire
que d'emblée en 24 heures il ya déjà des
gens qui se colle à d'autres d'accord
alors c'est vrai que la nuit tout est
filmé la nuit tout est filmé ouais alors
les vidéos vont sortir ou passé sera
donc les vidéos
oui il saisit enquête il ya plein alors
on ouvre donc il ya plein on a d'autres
infos donc sur sur koh lanta c'est vrai
que c'est il s'est passé beaucoup de
choses et c'est vrai qu'elle est
candidat donc ils sont exprimés dans les
médias notamment il ya eddy qui s'est
exprimé aujourd'hui à télé star il a
donné une interview il a décidé qui
serait exprimé à cause de l'ampleur
prise par la faire mais aussi car il ne
supporte pas l'injustice l'article donc
l'appel bruno mais son nom bien sûr son
prénom a été modifié candide c'est une
belle petite nana dit il sur le bateau
avant de sauter pour rejoindre la rive
elle était vêtue d'un fuseau orange
assez moulant on devinait ses sous
vêtements
ça m'a choqué quand on vient sur koh
lanta on est pudique pour voir candide
était un élément provocateur
si on veut mettre en avant sa plastique
c'est une autre émission qu'il faut
faire si on s'est exprimé sur un épisode
qui l'a marqué lors du tournage il a dit
je voyais trop de proximité entre
certains candidats comme si certains se
connaissaient déjà depuis des années
candide faisait partie d'un petit noyau
de quatre candidats très proches dont
eddy il faisait aussi partie entre y
avait trop de proximité
il était trop tactile trop rapidement et
sur eddy guyot donc ce gaz il dit c'est
un pape avant tout autant il peut avoir
un comportement un peu protecteur papa
gentil mais il ne laissait pas cette
impression de vouloir se taper
une gonzesse voilà donc il ya eu plein
de choses et je vous le dis avant-hier
dans var matin
il avait déjà dévoilé le témoin il y
avait déjà dévoilé le témoignage d'un
autre candidat
voilà donc tous les candidats commencent
à parler et je vous le dis il ya même
vous jean pierre castaldi votre père qui
a tagué qui attaquent les candides
renard jeu parce qu'il avait à me trop
de blancs trop de blancs c'est ça on
devrait donc tout le monde se rebelle
est-ce que vous avez de nouvelles infos
en norvège nous attendons l'annoncé
simplement que j'ai eus l'avocat des dix
matin qui me disaient qu'ils avaient en
tout cas sur son bureau
cinquante plaintes que même de
l'inspection du travail sur koh lanta
tessar korité récoltés au cours des
années et là dessus ils vont engager 50
procédure
les candidats qui sont plaints de la
modernité de traiter payer rapatriés sur
place bref c'est une fois qu'ils en
train de prendre une ampleur
considérable alors voyager les big bio
on a connu deux civils
je l'attendais tous et d'aiguillon voilà
qui qui qui qui s'exprime on attendait
tous qu'ils s'expriment sur il est
soupçonné d'agression sexuelle il a dit
j'ai suivi les policiers comme je n'ai
rien à cacher que je suis innocent je
n'ai même pas attendu que mon avocat
arrive pour commencé à m'expliquer il a
également dit avoir été choqué par sa
garde à vue il a confirmé que candide
renard a refusé la confrontation alors
c'est nouveau ça alors vous nous aviez
dit que annoncé la police qui a refusé
qu'ils se rencontrent ce moment là pas
du tout elle qui a refusé et à propos de
l'agression y est revenue sur la nuit du
quatrième au cinquième jour de tournage
et il affirme avoir été victime d'une
agression sexuelle de la part de
candidats tous les soirs j'ai dormi
entre un homme et la paroisse de la
cabane candidats l'était plus loin quand
les caméras langues sont revenus dans la
nuit pour nous filmer je me suis
réveillé et candide était à moitié sur
moi ça a été filmé et ça me disculper
complètement il s'est donc exprimé sur
télé star il a également livré une
interview sur closer et s'était dit sûr
qu'on dit le renard c'est une gamine
elle n'a pas mesuré l'ampleur de ces
accusations à mon avis elle a dû se dire
qu'on allait juste me sortir du jeu et
qu'elle allait sauver sa place je pense
qu'elle a fait ça par stratégie elle
savait que sa place était en danger au
prochain conseil voilà donc il dit
également je suis forains et dans le
milieu les gens me connaissent et vous
pouvez demander à qui vous voulez tout
le monde vous dira que je suis honnête
et que je ne comportent jamais comme ça
et sur sa garde à vue il dit que voilà
on l'accuse de l'avoir embrassé candide
elle dit qu'elle a senti ma barbe que
j'ai passé ma main sous son pull tout ça
c'est fou aujourd'hui donc et
d'aiguillon voit qu'on dit avoir
maintenu ses déclarations
bien sûr